okay we are
live let me
see takes a second to go up
here there we
go
everyone um we have a lot of cool stuff
to do
today nothing here I posted a few
things so we did the hyper parameter
tuning job for the
mooba
yesterday and it did very well in fact
it did well enough that it's going to
allow us to essentially spend today
finishing Auto balancing the game um and
then we should be able to just kind of
start doing cool stuff with it yeah uh
and then I'm hoping the project will
kind of drive itself for a bit after
this though we might end up having to
spend a good chunk of time on just
making the game easier to understand and
sort of like
Graphics animations and stuff um it's
not just flavor it is also important for
understanding what's going on so we'll
do a little bit of time uh we'll spend a
little bit of time on
that and we also got some results
overnight so uh I did this giant sweep
on breakout over the weekend it finished
I now started one on beam Rider so far
beam Rider has been crushed
completely yeah this is very very good
um I am a little a little bit confused
as to why it's not running longer and
longer experiments yet I think I'm going
to let this one go for a while um but I
did a little test with breakout and if
you just set the experiments to run for
longer it does do better which is weird
because carbs is supposed to
automatically run stuff for longer if it
would help so I think that there might
be a little issue with the carbs
implementation um I'm going to let this
collect a little bit more data before I
ask the author
of carbs about this um and see if they
have any ideas but I might end up having
to fix some stuff here but hey I mean
that just means that there's even more
potential for this to get better right
like these ridiculously good experiments
we've been running have all been at
relatively uh short experiment ranges
like maximum 20 minutes runtime so we'll
see where this goes from here I hope
that this does actually continue to
improve uh we're going to let this run
for a few more days I mean I would think
so when you look at something like this
one hold
this holy look at this yeah this is like
skyrocketing what oh no that's episode
length
uh oh funny enough it looks like there
is a run up here that did way better and
then it just was unstable or
something okay yeah this should
definitely definitely find some better
runs if we just leave this so pretty
cool we'll let this keep going for
now and we should start on the MOBA
So the plan for today
is the dev Loop is essentially going to
be that we like look at the game
parameters we try to make some changes
to the way that spells and attacks work
and all that stuff we run training for
minutes um we see if the agent learn to
use the new attacks if the classes are
balanced if like their various different
stats that we've collected look
reasonable and we'll keep doing that
back and forth a few times and then
maybe we'll swap a couple abilities
maybe we'll do some like other changes
but then basically once that is done
then we will be able to just like make
this thing look a little better and
we'll kind of be ready to throw together
some uh some public demos for this um
yeah so the one thing at a high level
that I haven't figured out yet how I'm
going to do yet is I have two major
things I'm working on in the immediate
future I have this video that I've kind
of been doing off stream though I did a
little of it on stream which is going to
be like the next big piece of content
for puffer I want to finish that
relatively soon um but then I also have
you know this huge simulation update for
puffer which probably we should have
released something by now but I want to
make it very good um and I don't want to
just do rolling release updates
either
so the thing I'm not sure about is how
many of these demos I want to run on web
essentially cuz like if I want this
thing to run on web I'd have to Port it
to C
which I could do and I would have a fun
time doing it but it would delay stuff
right and I don't know if I want to do
that I don't think I want to commit to
that just yet in either event so we'll
keep doing this for now and I'll think
about that but at the very least I'd
like to get this into a spot where like
I'm pretty confident that the models are
good and I can continue training stuff
and it'll work well
yeah let's take a quick look before I
start on the MOBA if there's any major
stuff seg
vaults we'll getting carb suggestions
looks like uh carbs is doing well on
control
Ms this is so funny it just
works offer box crash
thread uh this could
be Segal
good
okay and oh we have some contributor
stuff as
well Noah's breakout
thing and Nathan has pong let's see
done trained in two minutes on
CPU very very well done
it's awesome to see that we actually
have some people like starting to add
environments and stuff to
puffer these are two very very awesome
projects
G that's rough
handle
okay yeah I don't know Wan B was doing
weird things yesterday so I don't know
if I haven't anything to do there just
yet um
good let's do the MOBA stuff now I think
we're good to go um
right so if I recall where we left this
off
yesterday why is this running breakout
oh right cuz I I did a little sweep
that's fine um yeah that's that's fine
no big deal there so I will have to kill
that but that's no no big deal that was
just like a tiny test run basically I
just wanted to see what happens if you
ran longer experiments with breakout and
yeah you do actually get some better
stuff so that's
fine okay so we'll start running the
mooba and we will look at
the the Moa implementation so I think
what was happening is we we found a bug
in which you could you essentially had
unlimited
cooldowns um we fixed that and the
classes that were underperforming
actually performed as
expected but
then um the classes that underperforming
started performing as
expected but the two that were
overpowered stayed really
overpowered and I don't know why because
we'd like Nerf them into the
ground so the idea with the carry is
that it has very good scaling attack
damage right same as in the actual game
um usually you scale this with items
more but we just give it base scaling
has really bad stats and it doesn't have
great abilities but for some reason uh
the agents still think that the carry is
just really
good so we're going to figure out why
that is we're going to figure out why
the uh the mid laner or whatever the
burst class is overpowered as well and
we'll fix these and the nice thing is
that these experiments only take like 10
minutes and uh we can also like we can
start understanding how they're doing
after only a few minutes so we'll start
on
that let me see if I can make the stats
window a little better today I'd have to
make the chat or the camera smaller
smaller
uh can do a little bit let's just do
like
this
oops puffer moves down a little
bit and this goes over
here this car and now I can move this
down just a little
bit and I think this is going to yeah
that's going to mess it up isn't
it but it will fix
perfect so we can actually see the time
remaining at
least and this is a little easier to
read okay so already we
have Assassin is still
tank where the hero
kills
five assassin is still crazy
overpowered let's see what abilities are
being used so
skills so it's got this minion AOE
right it's got like this minion AOE that
scales it's got this TP that does damage
that's very strong and it's got this
move buff right and I think that we said
that we actually liked the way that this
felt when we played it so we wanted to
make make everything else stronger
rather than making this
weaker yeah this thing is very broken at
the
moment so we actually that actually
makes sense because that means that we
have to make we bring the burst and the
carry back up okay we bring the burst
and the carry back up to where I wanted
them to be so what if I just give the
carry 25 damage and do nothing
else for
okay I might actually just want to Dev
mostly on the server today I
think though if the Box goes down we'll
be in trouble but I think we'll be
okay Jas Wars at puffer box
so this is the remote box that I run the
experiments
build okay so now I what I want to see
is if giving the carry that extra
scaling damage alone makes it on par
with the assassin class or not
meantime in the meantime we should look
at the burst class which we also I just
nerfed that a whole bunch
right yeah so it got gig nerfed
here how much Mana does this class start
with
300 and then how much does
the the Assassin do with its TP damage
250 plus 50 times level
is that
good I think so
right what's the like the usual HP gain
for
level it's kind of hard to tell
here
um
100 I think like one 100 is the default
so basically this will chunk half your
health that feels good I think that the
base damage just has to go up on this
and the scaling goes up as
well I think this is now on par with the
Assassin's damage but this is a ranged
one
okay and it has follow up with its AOE
right yeah
this I can't do 50 times level because
that's again half your HP I think this
is 25 times level
maybe we'll see if it likes it
there and the cool thing is now we
should already be able to see if this is
working um so
hero kills okay so the carry is still
not performing anywhere near as well
even with these
changes right it's doing better I
believe than
before and it is starting to scale more
heavily I
think but yeah this CU just run away
with the game I think we give this a
little bit longer because it does look
like maybe it's starting to
outscale but I think it's probably just
too slow at the moment it needs some
help with its abilities early
on
so what skills is it currently using q
no W and
E I mean these just scale terribly at
the moment right
so it has an
AOE it has a
slow so we give it a little buff
right and yeah it's basically level with
the burst class so it's still not
good also I designed this game for 30
levels did DOTA used to be 30 levels now
it's 25 or something or did I just do it
wrong or is it now 30 and it used to be
25 cuz I thought when I looked on the
wiki it was 30
levels did I remember to rebuild I did
right
yeah okay so we'll run this again
and let's see if this does
better the goal is essentially to
produce like a level and skill usage
distribution that you would roughly
expect from a game like DOTA so like the
tank should have more damage received it
should probably have some selfhealing
done quite a bit of self healing done to
tank the extra damage support should be
healing know the rest of the team a
little bit and maybe have some utility
skills being used um the like Assassin
should have high kills right like
probably the uh carry should have really
high total damage dealt
right stuff like that
it's pretty cool to see just how
ridiculously fast these things
learn we're going to be uh we're going
to be able to get it faster than this as
well like the original hyper pram sweep
was based off of weird game mechanics
like the more well balanced or like the
better the game is and the like less
weird stuff you have to do think the
easier it'll be to get like consistent
learning
progress okay so now now let's see we
have Assassin is still
overperforming still early to tell for
the
carry assassin being strong early is
actually
fine but the thing is it's it like at
the moment it just keeps scaling too
fast it should either fall off or like
at least the other one should catch
up assassin have most kills is probably
fine though it's just that it shouldn't
have it has way too high damage
dealt maybe it's Auto attack scale too
heavily that's a thought
right hold
on I think it just has too much at the
moment it has like too much solo kill
potential and too much
scaling I have to think about this in
terms of like time to kill right
so if they're gaining 100 HP per
level and you gain 15 damage per level
then adds a second and a half or so to
time to
kill so wait at level here's another way
of thinking about this at level
30 you will have like
150 200 base attack with the base
yeah so it's like 10 seconds to kill
just with Autos but then you're probably
doing like a third with your
spells that's about right
I think it's just that this is too much
scaling as
all yeah I think this just scales too
heavily let's bring this down to 10
maybe and then we'll see how this looks
from
here let me check kills so
46 oh the carry caught up up actually
look at
that damage
dealt damage dealt it still scales too
heavily I
think I'm going to try it at 10 and
we're going to see if that makes a big
difference um but I do see that the
carry caught up but it caught up at the
very
here it still hasn't caught up in damage
which is like opposite I think the
Assassin should have like low damage but
High kills right because it
has it has like good uh like burst uh
burst like jump spell or whatever it's
like good for like solo kills and
stuff should be at least
I'm thinking of like I guess I'm
thinking of this based off of like
League junglers or whatever that like if
they're ahead a couple levels then they
basically will just like jump and solo
kill anybody but like if they're behind
or if there's like support like they
can't really do too much on their
own yeah this damage is still scaling
out of control though the kills now let
me see the
kills the carry caught up on kills so I
think it's in a good spot now and it is
using its skills
here at least somewhat though they're
not as impactable of course uh burst is
still
behind interesting that this is still
behind how much
damage this is somewhat far behind I
would
say yeah this should probably have more
kills
H damn I didn't think about how useful
running these simulations will be for
class balancing oh yeah like this is the
type of thing where I mean if I'm
looking for applications of this Tech in
Industry um of course it requires your
game has to like it has to run so so
fast for this to be feasible but like if
you can do it yeah you no longer need
beta testing or at least you need way
less of it cuz you're like okay we'll
just we'll just like go home for the
night and it'll be Auto balanced in the
morning but like if you make it really
fast then it can be okay we'll go get
coffee and it'll be Auto balanced
right this is going to be a really cool
thing in the future but for now we're
just using it to make the research Sims
which is almost even better because it
lets us do the research to make this all
work better faster
it's pretty
cool now mind you this didn't used to
work right like this is only because we
have all this stuff with puffer and all
like this autot tuning like usually the
research format when I was early on in
my PhD would be like you build something
like this and then you spend four months
suffering trying to get it to learn
anything it's so much better straight up
building the roads
yeah is pretty
cool let me think how I the thing is I
haven't played enough League or DOTA
it's it's actually ironic that the most
useful thing here for me would not be
like more RL experience or whatever it
would be like I If I were gold if I were
like gold in Dota or whatever the
equivalent is right like that that would
make this easier than anything else I
need like a plat plus player to just
tell me what the [ __ ] to do
I know that the ranks aren't like gold
platin DOTA it's like ascendant archon
or what I forget what the hell they are
but
yeah you know what I mean the same like
H how is the burst character not already
like insane it's not using its
W hold on
really it doesn't use its w at
all well
[ __ ] you couldn't pay me to head hunt
some salty Diamond
Player
yeah I don't know I grew up on MMOs like
by comparison the mobile Community is
really chill and friendly so hey Ash
welcome we're balancing this we're using
reinforcement learning to balance are to
help us balance our game which we're
using to do reinforcement learning
research so the problem is right here if
I give these um if I give
this I have to think of this in like ttk
right time to
kill if I give this two abilities that
it can cast at like the same time that
both scale with like half of the average
Health gain per level then this is just
going to be broken right
what did I give the Assassin wait maybe
the Assassin is
broken which game is this you're using
rain so this is this is like a miniature
version of DOTA kind of let me see do we
have I really should just have a go-to
gift for this but I think I can run it
real
quick let me show this in case anybody
hasn't seen this
work wrong render
mode okay so this is the wrong render
mode but yeah this is what it looks like
at a high level it's like the three lane
structure and then if I actually render
this with the reasonable render
mode render mode
human why didn't that
huh did bet break my [ __ ]
code I merged a PR yesterday I think he
broke my damn
I'm going to show the GIF online and
then I'm going to fix this and I'm going
to like probably yell at bet for
submitting a [ __ ]
PR I'll show the the gift that I have
online for this let me go find it
it looked kind of sketchy I shouldn't
have merged it but I figured out
whatever it was like 900 p.m. and I
wanted to go eat and go to bed okay so
this is the Moa this is what the Moa
looks like um we don't really have
graphics for it yet so it's like you
have a bunch of puffers the puffers are
the heroes they're like very slightly
different shaded puffers that are the
minions and the
neutrals um but yeah there are five
different classes you do have different
qw and E abilities there are three
abilities per class there are stuns
there are like slows there's health and
Mana there are Towers there are creep
waves you know it's it's most of the
major stuff you'd expect the one big
there two big exceptions I haven't done
Vision yet I will probably do Vision
we'll see how hard it is uh I probably
am not going to do economy just because
it's just like a pain in the ass for RL
and it's it's not going to add enough
for the amount of annoyance that it will
cause um but yeah it like you'll get a
pretty decent MOA out of it I think like
a decent one at least for research and
it runs at a million frames per second
so that's the main thing it runs fast
enough to just do hypers scale research
on let me go figure out what the hell
bet did this is his
PR or if I'm being stupid that's also
possible
well he took the keyword ARG out of this
so it wasn't rendering with the right
keyword
ARG oh the game yeah it's I mean it's
it's pretty stripped down for now
but it's not bad and it runs very fast
and like we're actually getting cool
Dynamics out of it
this is not
needed is that it did he just break
everything else let me
go why does this feel
slow oh because I usually like playing
at 2x speed we might change the base
speed still we'll
see yeah here we have
this what class am I playing oh I'm
playing assassin right now so
technically I have like this move speed
buff I haven't compiled the latest
version I guess but yeah this is the
game I think in this build I don't have
neutrals running for some dumb
reason but like I have abilities and I
can do stuff there Towers there's my
team
all right there you go
I he's a new
Dev it's just
funny I I didn't bother to read it
properly so or test it
let's
see as of the latest version
here we didn't check right we wanted to
check the scaling of the Assassin
abilities
right it basically just has
one technically it does also have this
so it's like a total potential of 70 but
it mainly just has one here this is 50
so I think that the burst in order to
keep up it has to have scaling above
that
um but it should really have more
follow-up damage shouldn't
it does have a stun hold on oh no it
doesn't need it doesn't need more f
follow up because it already has a stun
okay so we'll just
do this scales as 40 maybe the nuke does
then bet you broke
rendering I don't know what else to tell
you you broke the freaking
rendering I just did on stream you can
rewind the YouTuber or whatever like
it's it wouldn't actually pass the
correct render mode to the
MOBA it's I think either twitch or
YouTube one of them you can just scroll
back like I don't know five minutes
this might be
op 250 300 plus 70
scaling I think this is op I think this
is going to stay 25
right but wait doesn't that a Nerf
overall
q w Wait qw it doesn't use
its W it uses its q and its
e so this needs to be buffed so it'll
use
it I think it does need to be
70 feels good we'll see let's let's try
this
so this version of assassin is high
burst low sustain how much is the ulti
chunking the average enemy so there
isn't an ultimate at the moment I have
three skills I didn't Design This around
really long cooldown
ultimates um I might add that
later but it's going to be harder to get
RL to do stuff with that initially while
I'm running these like really short
tests it's it does have like a strong
skill though
um how much is the ulti so the skill
that the end the skill that it has at
the
moment which is it doesn't have like a
crazy long cool down I think it's like
it's like a 12 second coold down or a 14
second cool down so like once per
fight
um it is
a so at level one it is 30 damage the
average health is
500 and it scales with 50 per level and
the average Health gain per level is uh
is 100 so for most things it's like for
your typical thing uh your typical
opponent it's going to be chunking them
for like half their health later in the
game it has a 12se second cool down it
also teleports you onto them so you can
follow up with Autos the Assassin has
average Autos they're not amazing but
the idea is if you're one V one and if
you're a level ahead or a or two levels
ahead maybe then you basically you just
chunk them and you outscale them
depending on who you
dive assassin also has a move buff so he
can get around the map pretty fast and
uh he also has uh like just an AOE clear
on Minions that you can only Target on
minions but if you happen to be in the
middle of a minion wave it can Splash to
uh it can Splash to any other Heroes and
that will do like an additional 20 20%
of their health
probably so let's see
level at level 10 it's about a level
ahead of the burst and the
carry mid game
here tank is really far behind we'll fix
these two
assassin Carrie and assassin are now
about even it looks let's
see and now Carrie takes over in the
late game which is what we want 21 kills
kills I would like to see the carry have
more damage
overall um than the Assassin and and
like
more I I'd like the assassin to have
more damage and the carry to have more
kills but the thing is they're not
laning properly at this point they're
kind of all running down mid so I think
that when they're laning properly we'll
get to see that more so I'm not too
bothered by this I think that this is
good and 22 to 21 yep 24 to 20 yeah so
the carry out levels here the carry is
properly a carry now this is perfect um
burst
is about par how many kills does the
burst have have 26
kills this is pretty darn
good how much
damage I think the Assassin is dealing
slightly too much
damage or the burst maybe not
enough maybe this needs a very small
buff and then we'll fix the other
classes as for the
tank um yeah the tank is just in the
gutter right
now and uh support
is well tank needs the most assistance
at the moment here we're going to
screenshot this because the data at the
very end of the game it stops being
so we're going to give the burst a very
small buff
somewhere no love yeah the tank is about
to get Giga buff don't worry so burst is
using we can actually see q and E it's
not using its W skill at
all uh so it thinks that this skill is
just not good enough to use I
guess which is very
weird oh this is it's supposed to be 150
Mana not
200 and then let's give it uh let's give
it the same scaling as its nuke this is
kind of broken but we'll leave it like
this for
now I think this is basically going to
be like one shotting [ __ ] but we'll
see and then it stun doesn't do damage
at the very least which is
reasonable now let's take a look at the
tank
self-healing as a non- coder these are
really useful metric so far they should
be if you are interested in this type of
stuff learning to code is definitely the
way to go though it's uh it's a very
rewarding thing there's basically
there's nothing else in the world that
you can do where you can just like open
up your laptop and just make crazy [ __ ]
that changes the world with like zero
Financial or otherwise investment you
just like you just write a few thousand
lines of code and do something crazy
that's never been done
before it takes time to learn though it
takes much
time it's the same opportunity cost as
everything else bet but it's
the you don't get limited by external
stuff as much so it's a lot more just on
you whether stuff works or not
so let me see how how I'm liking this
skill set so what's the tank use it
likes it's Q it's w it actually looks
like it's very balanced in terms of uh
the skills that it's using it just
doesn't look like it's strong enough as
all so let's go like a take a look at
the tank stats
spec into Art and Design but I can read
a graph okay fair I have like no ability
with either of those so that's
fair hey we damage over
time self heal engage AOE
qwe and how much Mana gain does the tank
get I think it's low
right it gets 50 so same as the
carry so what's that that means at level
30 it'll
have 1,700 Mana
I mean that's still a
doing its damage is actually kind of in
a good
here so this is an AOE damage over time
this can be done five times per second
cuz they're five ticks per
second
um so it costs 50 Mana per
second to do
100 damage per second
level that feels
weak I think that the scaling on that
let me think so you do this for two
seconds you inflict 200
damage for 100
Mana I think the base is good I think it
just doesn't scale
enough so we're going to try we're going
to change this to be double the scaling
1.0 and then I suspect that if the tank
just catches up in levels a little
bit if the tank just catches up in
levels
I think that it'll get to use itself
feel
more
yeah let's just make these changes first
and we're going to see if this actually
is enough
I don't know what you do for worth uh
South CX but I will
say the tech artist is a thing that
exists artists that know a little bit to
like Implement a few little things with
their
designs they do some pretty cool
stuff though it is asking a lot that's a
lot of different skills to need
I know enough to not stress coders out
with unreasonable requests that is a
good spot to be
all right how is this doing so
so assassin is ahead
early tank is still way far
behind so actually that's a good data
point that the tank is behind
early this means that there's a problem
with its
initial maybe the problem isn't with its
scaling maybe it's with its initial
setup let's see does it catch back up or
is it I mean if you're like four levels
behind I think you just don't catch up
right
assassin is still ahead at level
11 and then Carrie should just be about
ready to take over mid game
even there it is Carrie passes assassin
at level 14
are you programming an MMO nope I've
already done that um already did that
for a long a long long time uh this is a
MOA where's the thing I had the little
the graphic around though I guess I can
just run it can
I here I'll just run it
here so this is what it looks like we've
got a little MOBA there's not really any
assets in it yet but the cool thing is
it's all reinforcement learning so all
these this right here this is our
assassin using its like boost
skill here we
have our oops
yeah there you go little MOA we're
currently balancing it by training
agents to play the game and then seeing
if they are good or not and seeing like
if some classes are doing way too much
better than
others assassin might need a small
scaling Nerf we'll
and Noah for breakout it feels like it
doesn't get any
faster and I Comon out all the Collision
checking it still runs around 500k
during
training without training at 10 mil
maybe it's Hardware or algorithm that
limits it no if you're getting um don't
profile end to endend training I can
check that on the puffer box like your
goal is if the environment runs at
millions of FPS per core then you're
good
I'm creating my first game without any
knowledge of programming good luck it
takes some
time it takes some
time this is not really games pro this
is like what you're watching here is
kind of games programming but there's
kind of there's a lot more to it because
this is really I'm making games to be
used for reinforcement learning research
so they are ultra high per performance
like a thousand times faster than you
would design a normal game to be and um
you know I'm like doing I'm training
agents in the loop on this to like
balance this to make sure it's good for
everything 10 mil just the environment
if that's single core then you're set
Noah and uh then I don't know what
you're training on but like the target
hardware for a million train throughput
is a 4090
so yeah I think that'll be fine and you
can uh if your environment is really
fast I don't know what the OB space is
if it's like some small state thing
though then uh it's probably going to
need larger than 496 Ford pass
batch started the easy part creating
Maps yeah well it takes some time
right okay so tank is just tank is in
the ditches at the
moment let's figure out why the tank is
this bad
like on paper it looks like it should be
good no is your repo ready for testing
he has it
online I
know I mean the tank has so much base
health and it gets pretty darn
good damage scaling as
yeah no what this is this is BET on
Discord he's one of the Pokemon
contributors
like I need to really think about ttks
here don't
I so if you get 100 HP per
level times 30 is 3,000 right
and then base damage is going to be like
300 I think if you have 10 per level so
yeah it's ttk is like 10 seconds of just
Autos which is
the tank having
more base damage scaling and still being
weak is
crazy I mean that seems like it should
be
broken it feels like I should be having
to Nerf it right now and not like figure
out why it isn't working
right did I just like mess up the math
Somehow
Here hold on how did I like just mess
the math up
one times player.
level so 100 DPS at base
good seems like that should be
good and then at
level 30 it's 50 de 50 so 2 50 DPS per
level is it still just not scaling
enough I think it's also weak is it weak
at base
level we're going to like
let's do like this and then I I'm hoping
that this should like just make it
broken we'll
see I mean these characters if I explain
them to you like at a high level they
sound broken like hey the tank has way
more HP than anyone else way crazier HP
scaling uh it has an ability that it can
just like Channel damage in an AOE and
continue doing that cuz it doesn't cost
much Mana it can just like freaking burn
everything in an area and do that like
pretty substantial impact it can
basically like heal 2third of its HP in
one button press of its like massive HP
total in one button press and it also
has an engage to get into fights that
seems like a really strong class but the
RL agents disagree the RL agents say hey
we're pressing all the buttons we're
using all the abilities and we still
can't make make
weird it should be broken now
right let's see it should at least
outlevel the support come on give me
that
much if everybody need is broken nobody
has broken syndrome
yeah but that's like the fun way for
games to exist right like everything
should be broken so nothing is broken in
this case it's like this seems like it's
broken and it's still underperforming
the other things that are
broken how is this
still okay wait maybe this is fine let's
see how let's see how it scales
damage received on the tank is
good right it's tanking damage oh yeah
look at that it's tanking
damage but it's falling behind in levels
already it shouldn't be falling behind
like the the other characters it should
be on
par native damage mitigation as a
percent
I don't want to have to implement more
mechanics globally to balances the thing
unless there's like a very strong reason
to because then I get into armor and I
have to get into like you know DOTA has
very complicated formulas for
this so if I can avoid doing that I
would prefer to but yeah this thing is
just
getting how is it just not
scaling work with HP healing Mana damage
increases they have a base damage that
increases uh every level they've got you
know spells that get stronger every
level you know it looked like this thing
was doing
okay but if I'm looking at damage
received right it's actually it is
tanking it's just it's falling behind
too much in levels for it to keep this
up right
I think what's going to happen is it's
going to fall behind because it's it's
just too many levels behind to be
[Music]
relevant yeah look it's level 10 and
like these guys have just Giga
scaled so now it's still received the
most damage but the the Gap I think is
starting to
close 10 to
16 where do you see 10 to
16 oh the level
yeah I mean that's just awful you can't
be I mean if we're designing this like
May the support should be two to three
levels
behind maybe the support's supposed to
be what actually like three levels
behind the carry maybe
usually towards the
end two levels depending
like they're not supposed to just fly
off in completely opposite directions
like
this the thing is it is actually tanking
damage like this is the damage here
received is good it has a high HP total
and it's actually you can see that 5K of
this is from its healing so it would be
21k but it's actually gone up to 26k
because of its self fuel here
hi there are you letting the model
choose the reward parameters or setting
them yourself a little bit of both I
have five manually designed reward
components that are like they're listed
here right there's a reward for getting
XP for taking Towers uh for going to the
enemy ancient there's an reward for
dying and there's yeah like one other
one I forget um and the actual weights
of these reward functions are determined
by Massive hyper parameter
sweep so I'm not setting the weights
manually but I've just said like eh
these are five things that seem like
they would be relevant reward components
and then the rest gets automated like I
ran 500 experiments over the weekend 100
billion steps worth of training and I
found some good hyper parameters based
on
that how is this tuning usually done for
real games seems near impossible
possible if you don't have a massive
player base it
is like you just have a bunch of devs
that are very experienced and they do
their best to guess right and then they
play the game themselves and then they
do like a Clos beta or whatever and then
they launch and then they balance like
they make patches right and it's very
very slow and very painful and you don't
have an opportunity to get good
feedback we have like Ultra easy mode
here because of this the only thing we
don't have is that our players can't
tell us something is broken right they
can't write like hey this ability is
just ridiculous
all we can see is like well they're
using this ability a bunch and they're
winning too much so probably it's
overpowered right so we have stats but
we don't have direct feed
back okay the tank is tanking it's just
falling behind in levels which means
that it
is qwe
why is it falling behind in
levels you can't just plug in an llm and
tell you how it's
feeling
tiny how are we supposed to specify the
render ARG in the Run
Creator yeah you can pass it through n
keyword args though which is what the
original code did that's not hardcoded
that's a default
level does this game have CS or economy
XP equivalence uh it does have it has XP
you get XP
for it's a little bit of a mix I didn't
want to implement the economy system not
because it would be hard to do the items
but because it would be annoying to plug
the neuron Nets into buying and like
buying items and like builds like that
um so what I did is I made it so you
have to last hit a minion to get XP and
then that XP is shared with nearby
allies it's split among nearby allies so
there is an incentive to like make sure
that you're last hitting your minions uh
there isn't a deny at the moment though
I could very very easily add that um so
there is like a there is an element of
it I it needs some iteration but yeah it
exists currently I'm just trying to
balance all the classes so that they're
at least like they look reasonable and
then uh we start scaling it and we start
doing like new features we start like
making the game look better we start
playing it more to see if it actually
feels like it's reasonable and uh we
start scaling experiments and stuff from
there do you have any sort of Replay
functionality to see decision modes
decisions made uh were you not here when
I showed it hold
live give it a
second it should run way faster than
this I'm technically running like 200
copies of this game in parallel or
something stupid now so you can just
play the game and these guys here these
are live running reinforcement learning
agents okay I just got merked but
yeah so you can just play it
yeah and also it's actually it gets
cooler than that because let me show you
the major thing that I implemented a
while ago I think I did this last
week so this is how cool we can get with
this project with puffer Li because of
how fast I've made
everything so I go to WBY here this is
like my training console right for my
big experiments and if I go to sweeps
here I should be able to
find so this is 512
experiments and I actually get ELO over
time so as I find different uh
experiment settings I find ones that get
higher and higher ELO so as I've run
these experiments I've also during the
process of training them I've evaluated
them against all the previous models and
we actually can see like I think it's
that 200 ELO difference is 75% win rate
so you actually can see that they're
like learning to beat their older
versions over time it's pretty
cool and you get optimal hyper
parameters you get like probabilistic
analysis of which settings actually
mattered you get all the curves for all
the different train runs you can filter
them so basically if the game is
balanced and makes sense and we have
stuff set up we can kind of automate
everything
else it's pretty
ago but like no amount of hyper
parameters is going to get you around
like hey the tank class just sucks right
so we have to still have stuff be
balanced
it's actually incredibly weird to me as
well that this is
bad this feels like it should be
good like dude how is this
bad is it just getting one shot like
let me
see entity
this is a really weird function could I
be at is there some logic that's screwy
here I should just play this right I
should just play it and see
this negative damage is healing for
allies
yeah uh that's how it
and I need to
do
right tank is
[Music]
index
three so I can just play as the tank if
I just set I just have to set debug
flag I just do three
here and I should be able to play
this I currently don't handle invalid
render modes but I could just do that
somewhere okay so I have yeah this is
the tank it has 700 health and I should
be able to like
does reset you occasionally I forgot
about
that I need to self heal come on
it needs a lot of Mana there we go I
fully self
yield
then level
three I don't think I need to sell fuel
here I'm going to use this Q to burn all
these
minions this feels strong
it feels like this would even feel good
to play if I had like just a better oops
how about I burn all of them yeah I just
cleared all of
them do the skills just take too much
Mana is that what it
is it might just be that they take way
too much Mana right
okay I think that's probably let's try
that I bet they're out of Mana how many
players per side 5v5 same as DOTA a lot
of the stuff is One V one like is just
like taking one V one or like one to one
with h DOTA a lot of it is just
DOTA let me try giving it a
significantly better uh Mana cost
here let's see what happens if this is
just like not
expensive if this makes a
difference because this feels like a
good
ability so this is 25 Mana per second
now how did you get the entropy of MOA
so
entropy also there isn't Mouse position
action
space not at the like
how's it
going we're balancing the Moa today it's
going pretty quick as
on it's still falling behind but not as
aggressive
so is that what it was the tank just
actually has Mana problems
is XP shared or solo uh it's shared in
AOE it's like if you're close enough to
your allies when you kill something it's
shared in the
yesterday I was reluctant to add it but
it was like it was really breaking the
game not having stuff be shared like
DOTA is
you don't get XP though if you don't
last
hit like your team nobody gets XP if
there's no last hit
done what are you doing at 400 p.m. on a
Tuesday I mean yeah this is my
job this Sim is going to be um I mean if
you think about it this Sim is like a
really complicated and interesting
environment for use in reinforcement
learning research and testing algorithms
right it's way higher performance like a
thousand times faster than basically
anything else out there
you're doing work I'm talking about
viewing I mean what are you doing on a
Tuesday like you're watching the future
of reinforcement learning being built
live
right I wouldn't be doing this stuff if
I didn't think I can really just like
solve a whole bunch of major things in
this like just revamp the whole field
right that's the only reason this is
worth doing is because I think I can
actually do it
[Music]
tank is still
behind it is tanking it's doing its
rooll job I don't like how far the level
is though
behind anodically a game changer for QA
and testing it's way more than that man
that's like a like that's a side effect
this is
like way more
broadly this is RL is not advancing at
the pace it should be it's been like
stuck because all the experiments take
so damn long and there are no complex
environments that you can actually train
fast so like basically half of the
research papers published in this field
are just wrong because they're conducted
with insufficient experimental
evidence like half of the like I
basically at this point when I read a
new paper in
RL I just assume it's wrong until proven
otherwise do the agents act in distinct
phases during the game is their behavior
consistent across time they're pretty
stupid at the moment um like this is a
pretty basic
setup but uh once we iterate on this a
little bit a little bit more the hope is
that we learn all that stuff
so a fun fact with this is once this is
fully optimized we're going to be able
to match roughly half of the data
throughput of the entirety of open AI 5
like the huge open AI project we're
going to be able to get about half that
on one GPU not a thousand
one working in rlf we consistently run
into that wall yep oh
yeah and in rhf you don't even have half
the problems that we have trust
me we got
demons we got some real demons to
exercise I said data I I said data bet I
didn't say model
size chat jippy may or may not assume
Onyx May
exist wait
what chat jippy may or may not assume
Onyx may exist in an embedded
environment I'm intrigued seemingly I
don't know what that means
Jason if you want embedded stuff though
I released this
yesterday this is running in the browser
this is is running RL agents in your
browser
um 100% client side so yeah this is a
fun thing you can play
[Applause]
with I'm a little conflicted about this
cuz I think the tank is in a good
spot it just
it's just under
leveling like yeah at the end of the
game it catches up
but let me think why does the tank get
damage received is very good right it's
done the tank job look at healing
received it's healed itself
30k do you want
hard no I don't want hardcoded args for
render mode to suede runtime
arcs is it just not getting last hits
relative to its teammate it shouldn't
matter if you're nearby and a teammate
gets last hit the XP is
proximity not really I could add it
but I mean I don't know what it tells me
Heroes killed slash
tank is
46 the thing is it is doing its job it
is tanking I just don't know why it is
falling behind in levels cuz like I
would think if it is tanking right it
should be getting all the
XP maybe it's that the tank is dying
because it's getting I don't know it's
weird when it backs up to heal it's not
backing up to heal they're not smart
that smart yet they just they will go
forward and then they'll mash the heel
button like they won't actually back off
they just keep going
forward basically they're smart enough
to like Rush The Objective and use
skills at the
moment I mean I like how much do you
want out of these right these are like
they're trained in a few
minutes is there a death counter I
should add a death counter shouldn't I
why don't we add a death counter
that's
what e
I love how easy that is it literally
took like 30 seconds to add that metric
and get it integrated with the
entire like everything that we're doing
here assuming it's working of
course looks like it is
the architecture of this thing is
basically a meme it's so funny it's just
like what if we just made an entity
struct and everything's an entity so we
can just add properties to that struct
and not care and be
done it's particularly fun because it's
actually very very
the see the Assassin's actually what we
expect right it's not playing well so
it's getting a lot of kills but it's
also just dying a lot
right cuz it's like running in killing a
thing and then dying because it's like
not planning on escaping or
anything tank is not dying any more than
the other
characters Carrie is getting bullied
because of course it is getting bullied
early in the game
hard I don't know why it's this far
behind like you see right here that
it's I mean it's it's level with the
support now but the support needs to get
ahead as well 16 18 17 yeah it needs to
be way higher up let's actually
screenshot this CU this is probably the
most indicative portion of the game here
this is like the mid game needs to be
balanced
right mid late
game right here the tank has how many
kills
maybe we're not sharing XP
kills maybe we're not sharing XP correctly I could have that logic
correctly I could have that logic
wrong break out XP by Source
potentially I mean I could also just
look at it
XP if you're targeting a player you get
the the XP for killing the target
otherwise you get whatever this
is
um this is the range sharing logic
so the index cuz it like we number the
players zero through 10 or whatever
so if you're on radiant your player zero
through five if you're on dire it's five
through 5 through nine so 0 through four
5 through N I should
say uh by default they're not in range
we check for the number of targets uh
number of allies that are in
range we go through five
teammates we're going to get the first
player on our team which is either zero
or five plus I so that is each agent on
your team we're going compute the
distance between the player that has
killed
stuff
um this is kind of weird I guess it
should probably be
the XP radius should probably be
centered on the Target
right I don't know if that makes a
difference
is there range vers melee
damage technically I think all the
skills some skills only work in like a
small AOE around you but most of them
have the same attack
range struck is smart I was getting
slightly annoyed having to log
things
yeah
so Nathan this is like the critical
piece of infrastructure that makes all
this stuff work and if I could figure
out how to replicate this in purec
nicely I would just do it that way but
numpy structured arrays allow you to
have a fixed memory array of
structs that if you look at it in numpy
it'll give you like an array where the
object type is a it's a structured array
so you can do like players of 0 through
5. health for instance or you can do
players. health of like 0 through five
um you can do like know just players of
0 through five to get all five players
all their stats and then that same
memory is mirrored to see so you don't
ever have to copy anything it's very
very
nice so this says that if you're that
anything that's nearby the player that
kills something is going to be marked in
range and
then we divide by the number of players
that are in
range we get the agents that are in
range
here we give them
Ward we level up Allies if
needed this is important right they get
XP they get leveled up
potentially and then they get their
their level up
stats I don't see anything wrong with
this
I could make distance based on the
target I don't see if that will make any
huge
we have to Define it up here because the
target
maybe if like the target is in melee
range this could happen but
like I don't think that this should make
a
difference I could be
wrong let's
correlated well yeah for the most part
they should be right it's really hard to
get kills when you're
behind I mean these guys also don't push
as a team so if you like if you just
like solo run it down mid the higher
level you are the more minions you're
going to kill before you
stuck
uh is this
stuck what's going on here
I messed something
up I don't think so
underscore the reason for the underscore
is we compute it before we kill the
Target because once we kill the target
it could be reset so we want the
position of the target before they they
die interestingly though it seems to be
hanging now let me hold
on this like bizarre let me just run
this again to see if this is actually a
thing
I don't know how the hell the change
that I just made would make this get
unless I just really slowed the Sim down
somehow
track could be Wan
B I doubt it but it could be Wan B
okay so this thing is stuck um that's
very very
weird is this thing stuck because of the
change that we made if I just
how the hell does this make this thing
like not how does this make this thing
infinitely
Loop if abs
[Music]
whatsoever should only apply to allies
what do you mean
it's also just possible that I made this
code block really
slow
right do I seriously have to compile
this for H uh the HTML for this